oh ja
mir jetzt zugeschaltet unser bild
reporter aus münchen kelkheim
wir haben jetzt gerade das video gesehen
am anfang brennt es etwas und dann kommt
es zu dieser explosion was genau ist er
heute nachmittag in münchen passiert ja
gegen 16 und 30 krachte der kran gegen
die oberleitung hier finden bauarbeiten
statt für die neue s bahn zentrale und
heute mittag gab ist in münchen ein
kleines gewitter die feuerwehr rückte zu
30 einsätzen aus und da gab es auch
heftige sturmböen dabei wurde der kran
unkontrolliert gegen die oberleitung die
15.000 fast geschleudert und der strom
hat ist dann durch den kran zum boden
geflossen und hat sich dann an den füßen
entladen deswegen auch diese heftige
explosion dort sind sogar bretter
verbrannt und betonplatten explodiert
wurden den menschen dabei verletzt
zum glück wurde wirklich niemand
verletzt der dort der dort gearbeitet
hat denn der krank wird per
fernsteuerung bedient und die leute die
den karren gesteuert haben konnten sich
dann zum glück retten bevor es dazu
größeren verletzungen kam
die s bahn musste erstmal unterbrochen
werden am münchner ostbahnhof wie
sieht's jetzt aus geht der
schienenverkehr normal weiter der
schiffsverkehr wird erst morgen früh
sehr wahrscheinlich normal weitergehen
derzeit ist ein ersatzverkehr
eingerichtet der die s bahn musste
ausweichen auf die schienen des
fernverkehrs derzeit sieht man auch
hinter mir wie die leute arbeiten hier
damit dass alles wieder ordnungsgemäß
funktioniert dazu musste eine spezial
locker angefordert werden die hier am
münchner ostbahnhof steht die einen kran
drauf hat und wir haben zum beispiel
nämlich das seil das kranz bergen konnte
weil da hat sich keiner ran getraut da
könnte noch reststrom braucht sein
einziges problem war nur derjenige der
diesellok fahren kann und in wohnt in
augsburg und musste erstmals augsburg
anreisen deswegen hat es da noch mal
eine stunde länger gedauert
vielen dank einem live aus münchen zu
diesem doch heftigen bildern die uns
erreicht haben mit der guten nachricht
dass dabei niemand verletzt worden ist